boone pickens you got a wing or anything
now are you never know what do you do
are you triple threat you never know
boone pickens said you got a wipeout
opec well the the pressure on opec let's
be clear is enormous we have enormous
quantities of new supply coming on
stream we have mexico liberalizing their
energy economy and and lackluster demand
so what's opec going to do the the the
they're notorious for cheating on each
other
venezuela is running around the world
the oil minister from venezuela is going
to libya to qatar saying hey we need to
cut production and then saudi arabia i
think is looking at the rest of them
saying wait a minute we're the only ones
that are likely to cut production the
rest of you are gonna free ride along
with us but let's say for the sake of
argument that they all get it together
that they all hold hands and they sing
frozen songs together do they skate and
skate do they still have the pricing
power once they do that i don't think
they do i think that's okay I think OPEX
power has really diminished if not
completely vanished over the last few
years you look at what's happened here
in the u.s. just in the last few few
years you look at the increased
productivity in the US oil market or us
drilling sector aia just last month came
up came out with some numbers that
showed that the average nuwell in the
Bakken in North Dakota is increasing
productivity by a hundred barrels of oil
per month I mean our per day rather is
your incredible productivity gains so
even if OPEC decides something the US
oil and gas freight train is going to
continue on do you equate OPEC with
Saudi Arabia well clearly because
they've always been the swing producer
they've always been the one with excess
capacity and the one that was first to
to take a hit in terms of sales but the
Saudis remember the ones now who have
said to the other OPEC members we're
gonna protect our market share first
what happens in the American West the
Texas Bakken as the smaller players
start to dry drop out do you have larger
players getting together and creating
pricing power the way OPEC did oh I
doubt it I mean you know where they got
a coordinator I don't see that happening
at all I don't know what Doug's what
does you know I wrote it on the street
calm a couple weeks ago about a possible
Golden Swan the dissolution of the VOC
well before the recent price decline and
my question to you is I think in some
measure the perception by the investment
community is that this decline in oil I
call it oil they some of that is
accruing sort of like a Golden Swan
because you are famously cranky but you
you're you're talking happy right now
well this is well hey let me get to the
bottom line oh the perception by the
investment community is that the oil the
lower oil prices is going to be boon to
the economy because it increases
disposable income and of course the
oppressed middle class will benefit but
the fact of the matter and the question
I have to you because you know the this
business is much better than I is that
there's a lot of negative fallout sure
in terms of employment related to the
production of shale a really good point
if you look at wala Steiner is a
economist at Purdue last September he
estimated a year ago he estimated that
the shale Gale is added three percentage
points to US GDP that's 500 billion
dollars of economic activity so we've
already seen Continental Resources with
halcones and others say they're going to
cut drilling in the next six months
that's going to mean fewer jobs you know
while we're short so when I see an
article this morning and I got up about
when you got up there is there's a cover
story entitled North Dakota Bank is the
returns are the envy of JP Morgan and
Goldman area of the shale play so when I
see that sort of thing as a short seller
you know my my ears pick up and that's
the top so there could be some some
economic adverse economic ramifications
on pain for the investors in North
Dakota that look at the the rental
market in Williston I was in North
Dakota just a few weeks ago they were
talking about average apartment rentals
in the in Williston being $2,000 a month
for small apartments I mean it's really
got
I have two sons Davis is shortened to
stop paying their rent